Tesla Incorporated seems to be making
lots of headlines these days and at this
rate there's no stopping them if you're
a fan of tech like me you'd know their
advances are massive and the latest one
of them is the humanoid robots that
could be used by you and me mind-blowing
yeah well let's get into it Tesla AI Day
summary CEO of Tesla Incorporated and
Tech Giant Elon Musk has brought out the
newest prototype of a humanoid robot
being created by his automobile company
the robot named Optimus came out on
stage in an event in Silicon Valley
where it waved to the crowd and lifted
its knees the tech giant said that
Optimus was still in development but
could be sold to people in a couple of
years the company's Engineers state that
the mass-market Tesla Bots would be
experimented with by operating some
tasks in the car plants and that sounds
reasonable to me the model was wheeled
onto the stage during a yearly Tesla AI
Day presentation the audience was shown
a clip of the bot completing easy tasks
such as carrying boxes watering plants
and lifting metal bars the controversial
billionaire explained that the humanoids
would be manufactured on mass at a price
way lower than you expected at twenty
thousand dollars and would be made
available in five years or less musk
talked about expecting abundance in
future the CEO added that is an
essential change of civilization quite
different from what we're used to I
can't wait Financial reviewers and
investors have been uh skeptical about
Tesla turning to Robotics and I can
relate they instead advised the company
to concentrate on programs closer to the
company's main business of electric
vehicles however musk asserted that he
wished to decipher one of the most
difficult issues with AI how to develop
Machinery that can replace a human being
sounds weird I know the attack Overlord
who once gave caution about artificial
intelligence becoming a danger to the
human race explained that Tesla sought
to make certain that the evolution to a
civilization in which robots performed
the jobs and humans got the advice was a
protected one we always want to be
careful we don't go down the Terminator
path he warned making reference to a
Blockbuster movie about to kill a cyborg
musk added that the company was
designing safeguards comprising a stop
by that cannot be altered thank goodness
I would just hate to be featured in
another Terminator movie Elon also
maintained that shareholders of the
company would decide if the company was
socially accountable is the humanoid
Tesla bot necessary fans of Elon Musk
and Tesla me included were fascinated by
the reveal of Tesla bot in California on
the 30th of September I equally liked
the theatrics but I don't think I'm the
only one wondering why Optimus had to be
you know human-like while the fans and
followers of musk despise any criticism
whatsoever musk himself has explained
that Optimus is nothing close to ready
for release the idea made for Tesla Bots
is that they are qualified to serve in
human environments with human tools
folks might feel more at home working
with a robot that resembles them I mean
if they're designed to look like me then
they look great no matter what but the
question arises how practical are they
Owen Nicholson chief executive of Slam
call which specializes in the
sensor-driven vision said a lot of
companies work in the area of humanoids
because it's interesting for the public
to see but wheel based robots and even
drones are so much easier to control the
amount of work that goes into just
getting a humanoid to stand upright is
huge the robotics behind the Tesla bot
looks okay after all Tesla is no
newcomer in this field however Nicholson
asserts that by the time of release the
humanoid would have developed into
something more practical Nicholson adds
that he'd put some dollars into creating
more wheelbase robots to be honest I've
seen a whole bunch of robots in
different form factors created to clean
teach play chess and other games sing
and dance whatever you could think of
someone somewhere is probably in the
works to create a robot for it and in
all of these I have picked out two
things some robots work a lot better
than others and presentations hardly
ever go to plan robots these days have
improved relatively quicker than human
beings in the last 10 years the robots
of this year are way more qualified than
the ones that were produced years ago
although it has been proven over and
over again that the most remarkable
robots happen not to resemble human
beings warehouse robots Precision
surgery robots and window cleaning
robots and none of these robots are
human-like the expectation may also be a
fraction of the issue humanoid robots
may be anticipated to work like human
beings accomplishing a bunch of very
tasks like holding a baby making a
coffee and mowing the lawn the perfect
companion however Professor Helen Hasty
of the national robotarium in Edinburgh
says humanoids are not expected to be
able to multitask she said what's most
important is that the robot is fit for
the task it is designed for for instance
a robot built to labor in the kitchen
might not need any legs but Wheels
instead also robots built to operate
with weak folks like in care homes for
example may be adequately fitted to
resemble a human being but of course not
too much I for one do not look forward
to getting freaked out in my old age it
is a splendor well known as The Uncanny
Valley it connotes that if something
resembles a human being but not
believably so that thing comes to be
unsettling and even scary in Professor
Helen hastey's own words if it's too
human-like it will put off the human and
I couldn't agree more musk's plan for a
useful and marketable Tesla bot other
automobile companies like Honda Mojave
and Toyota motor have formulated
humanoid robot models capable of doing
technical acts like shooting a
basketball for instance however Tesla
Incorporated is unaccompanied in lifting
the opportunity in the market for a
marketable humanoid robot that could be
very useful and capable of working in
the factory the next era of Tesla Bots
would make use of Parts designed by the
company including a chip system a 2.3
kilowatt hour battery pack situated in
the robot's torso and actuators to steer
its limbs the Tesla bot is built to
weigh 73 kilograms Engineers of the
company who like Elon were all putting
on black t-shirts with a portrayal of
metallic robot hand creating the shape
of a heart during the presentation
explained how they formulated the Tesla
Bots features even in Parts like how the
fingers can move with an emphasis on
bringing down the price of production we
are trying to follow the goal of the
fastest path to a useful robot that can
be made of volume musk explained he
asserts that by creating a robotics
Enterprise the company is altered during
the extent of a known goal assertion
that has come to be a fraction of its
attraction to climate activists and
investors by dedicating to hastening the
world's shift to sustainable power
Optimus is not directly in line with
accelerating sustainable energy the CEO
said I think the main mission does
somewhat broaden with the Advent of
Optimus to you know I don't know making
the future awesome Elon has defined the
occasion as aimed at recruiting hands
and the engineers present on stage
answered to a brilliant crowd the
engineers narrated the procedure by
which the company formulated robot hands
and made use of crash simulator
technology to assess the tesla-bot skill
to fall flat on its face and not break
it was amazing stuff they really put on
a show Elon Musk who has previously
spoken about the dangers of AI said the
total rollout of Tesla Bots was likely
to alter civilization however he
explained he reckoned the company's
shareholders needed to have a part in
vetting their actions if I go crazy you
can fire me he said this is important
the reactions from fans and followers on
Twitter weren't quite positive
concentrating on the moment of Tesla's
Growth Action since August 2021 when the
company announced its project with a
publicity stunt featuring someone in a
white suit simulating a human robot if
there's one thing musk knows how to do
it's put on a show Henry Ben Amore a
robotics professor at Arizona State
University said musk's price Mark of
twenty thousand dollars was a decent
proposition since existing costs are
around one hundred thousand dollars for
humanoid robots there's some discrepancy
between sort of the ambition and what
they have presented Amore said when it
comes to dexterity speed the ability to
walk in a stable fashion and so on
there's still a lot of work to be done
also Aaron Johnson a mechanical
engineering professor at Carnegie Mellon
University equally mentioned that the
robot's necessity was uncertain what is
impressive is that they got to that
level so quickly what is still a little
murky is what exactly the use case is
for them to make millions of these he
said the company also talked about its
long-awaited self-driving Tech at the
occasion self-driving cars first
autonomous robots next back in May
muscus asserted that the most valuable
car maker in the world would be worth
nothing without attaining maximum
self-driving ability and it encounters
thriving regulatory inquiries and also
technical hurdles Elon said months ago
that beta testing of the company's
entire self-driving ability would be
available for Global release by the end
of the year however certain restrictions
depict hurdles musk prefers to have a
priority and in 2022 it looks like it
will be humanoid robots the Tesla Bots
would be the most significant things the
company operated on in 2022 the
tesla-bot Optimus would utilize the same
AI systems that are supported empowering
Tesla cars musk also stated that the 508
humanoid robot would feature a screen on
its face and would be capable of lifting
150 pounds and traveling at about 5
miles per hour earlier musk told his
investors that the Tesla bot's first use
would be at a Tesla Factory but later in
future he envisions it assisting to fix
labor scarcities well I don't know about
you but I believe that bumblebee would
be so proud of Optimus what do you think
about humanoid robots if you like this
video make sure to click a card on your
screen for more content like this